by coincidence a very short time ago
Senator Bob Dole and I held a press
conference in Washington Bob and I and
Howard Baker and tom daschle for former
Senate Majority Leader's to Republican
to Democrat are joining in an effort to
try to agree on a health care reform
program that we will make public after
the election in the hopes of generating
and spurring debate there are other
commissions and groupings that are doing
it and we've said we're going to enter
it with an open mind we're going to try
very hard to reach agreement among
ourselves we're all good friends
personally and that'll help a lot but so
I wouldn't try to prejudge it at this
point and and and honestly a time this
is not the kind of thing you can reduce
to a bumper sticker and a slogan it
requires a thoughtful comprehensive
discussion I think the system is of
course capable of doing it I think there
are two stages in the legislative
process on major issues that affect
pretty much the whole country the first
is a consensus among the American people
that a problem exists and I think we've
reached that stage the second is a
consensus on what is the best solution
of the problem and we clearly have not
reached that stage but I have heard in
the past several months not just in the
campaign but outside the campaign many
many more voices recognizing the need
for some change including many who are
part of the system what the phrases
stakeholders in the system people who
deliver health care people whose
occupations are involved in healthcare
and of course patient advocates I
emphasize that while I'm not going to
get into the details of what the program
ought to be for the reasons I've just
stated that you can't just look at
coverage you have to look at the quality
the manner in which care is delivered
and the financing of the system there is
a huge amount of waste in the Americans
it does not necessarily follow in this
case that if you spend more money you
get a better result I'm not sure that
follows in any case but it surely
doesn't follow in this case so it'll be
tough and obviously will have to be a
bipartisan approach because while it's
likely that Democrats will increase
their margins and the House and Senate
it's not likely that Democrats will
increase their margin in the Senate to
the 60 votes that are necessary to cut
off debate so you're going to need some
kind of bipartisan effort which is why
the four of us are getting together to
try to help out in that area